ahora que tenemos la fórmula del
desplazamiento en función de la
velocidad inicial y del tiempo vamos a
poder graficar el espaciamiento la
aceleración y la velocidad en función
del tiempo para que comprendamos
perfectamente qué es lo que sucede con
la pelota al ir subiendo y a ir bajando
ya tenemos entonces la fórmula del
desplazamiento y también tenemos la
fórmula de la velocidad final que es
esta fórmula
y bueno tenemos que nuestra aceleración
de la gravedad es menos 9.8 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado es negativa porque
nuestra convención es que todo lo que va
a dirección hacia abajo es negativo
todas las cantidades que tiene ubicada
todo el vector que tiene que va hacia
arriba va a ser una cantidad positiva y
ahora vamos a proceder a graficar
entonces vamos a hacer espacio aquí
y vamos a hacer primero nuestra gráfica
del desplazamiento
con respecto al tiempo
entonces tengo mi eje de el cambio en el
tiempo
tengo mi eje del desplazamiento y voy a
graduar 1
y aquí vamos a tener
5 10 15 20
metros metros aquí vamos a poner es la
unidad de aquí son metros aquí en el
tiempo son segundos y aquí tenemos cinco
diez quince veinte y aquí en el tiempo
tenemos uno dos tres cuatro y esta es mi
gráfica
del desplazamiento
disculpen la letra que no me sale tan
bonita aquí usando este aparato pero
bueno espero que se entienda ahora voy a
poner describir los ejes de la velocidad
contra el tiempo esta es diferente
porque aquí voy tengo valores positivos
y negativos
y tengo aquí el eje del cambio del
tiempo esto es mi velocidad
valores positivos y negativos en el
tiempo sigue siendo 4 segundos 1 2 3 4
34 y de la velocidad voy a tener en la
velocidad se mide el metro sobre segundo
voy a tener aquí 10 metros sobre segundo
aquí arriba 20 metros sobre segundo y
aquí voy a tener menos 10 metros sobre
segundo y aquí menos 20 metros sobre
segundo voy a hacer otra tabla más que
es mi tabla de la aceleración esta es
muy sencillita
tengo mi eje que puede ser aceleración
positiva o negativa tengo mi eje del
tiempo antes de que se me olvide voy a
poner la etiqueta de que esta gráfica
anterior es la de velocidad
velocidad
y esta es la del desplazamiento entonces
tengo igual pero esta es la de la
aceleración y como mi aceleración es
constante y es de menos 9.8 metros sobre
segundo
yo tengo aquí
esta es mi aceleración
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado es la
unidad
y aquí tengo mi marca de menos 10 y el
9.8 más o menos está por aquí y como es
aceleración constante no importa el
cambio en el tiempo
voy a tener la misma aceleración
entonces así queda mi gráfica de la
aceleración
y aparte voy a hacer una pequeña tabla
vamos a ponerla de un color azul bonito
y esta tabla voy a graficar
más o menos así
no tengo impulso hoy ustedes disculpen
pero trataré de hacerlo lo más derechito
posible está que lo mejor voy a tener
los valores aquí de él
desplazamiento
perdón mi primer valor va a ser el
cambio en el tiempo
en la siguiente columna voy a tener mi
velocidad final o la velocidad en este
tiempo
y en esta otra columna voy a tener ahora
sin mi desplazamiento entonces comienzo
en el tiempo cero me encuentro aquí en
este punto en todas las las gráficas
bueno tengo
cuando tengo el tiempo cero revisando
nuestras fórmulas de la velocidad
la velocidad final es igual a la
velocidad inicial más la aceleración por
el cambio en el tiempo
cuando tengo mi tiempo
igual a cero
este término es igual a 0 por lo que
multiplicado por cualquier cosa va a ser
igual a 0 y aquí voy a tener el valor de
la velocidad inicial entonces
mi velocidad final o mi velocidad en el
momento del tiempo igual a cero va a ser
igual a mi velocidad inicial y mi
velocidad inicial la tenemos aquí
definida como 19.6 metros sobre segundo
entonces mi velocidad final va a ser
igual a 19.6 metros sobre segundo si yo
gráfico aquí mi velocidad en el tiempo
cero es mi velocidad inicial 19.6 aquí
un poquito abajo del 20 aquí voy a estar
y si quiero conocer mi desplazamiento
en el tiempo cero el desplazamiento es
igual a la velocidad inicial por el
cambio de tiempo el cambio de tiempo
aquí es cero entonces ese término es
igual a cero
aquí también tengo mi desvía en cambio
en el tiempo que es cero esto también se
vuelve cero por lo que mi desplazamiento
va a ser cero no lo voy a estar moviendo
aquí en mi gráfica mi desplazamiento en
el tiempo pero va a ser ser voy a estar
aquí
ahora entonces vamos a poner estos
valores en la gráfica para el tiempo
cero mi velocidad inicial va a ser
bueno mi velocidad final o mi velocidad
en este momento va a ser de 19.6 y el
desplazamiento va a ser igual a cero
ahora qué pasa cuando estoy en el primer
segundo entonces mi cambio en el tiempo
es igual a un segundo cuál va a ser mi
velocidad final mi velocidad final va a
ser igual en este caso
a la velocidad inicial más la
aceleración por el cambio en el tiempo
en este caso este valor es 1 por lo que
la aceleración multiplicada por 1 que da
igual la aceleración y esto va a ser
igual a mi velocidad inicial que son
19.26
metros sobre segundo más mi aceleración
qué es
la aceleración es menos
recordamos que la aceleración es va
hacia abajo es negativa por la
convención entonces menos 9.8
metros sobre segundo y si hacemos esta
resta pues va a quedar igual a 19.6 -
9.8 queda igual a 9.8 metros sobre
segundo esta es mi velocidad cuando
tengo un segundo
9.8 en la gráfica en este segundo 9.8 va
quedando más o menos por acá voy uniendo
los valores de este punto a este punto
para que veamos más claro que está
pasando y ahora calculemos el
desplazamiento entonces el
desplazamiento con esta fórmula es mi
velocidad inicial por el cambio del
tiempo que es un segundo entonces me
queda mi velocidad inicial mi velocidad
inicial es d
19.6
metros sobre segundo
más la mitad de la aceleración por la
cambio del tiempo al cuadrado el
cuadrado de 1 sigue siendo 1 por lo que
este valor es la mitad de la aceleración
entonces tenemos que la aceleración
que es negativa va a ser igual a menos
la mitad de 9.8 esto es igual a 9.8
entre 2 los usamos nuestra calculadora
ahorita ya puede sacar mi calculadora
y entonces tenemos el 9.8 entre 2
4.9
4.9 entonces esto nos va a quedar
si yo restó 4 puntos 9 a 19 puntos 6
19 puntos 6 menos
4.9
me queda 14.7 el desplazamiento 14.7 de
esos metros si observamos de esta
fórmula
vemos que la velocidad de cerca de
metros sobre segundo lo multiplicamos
por el tiempo en segundos por lo que los
segundos en una línea de más queda en
los metros y esto se suma a lo que es la
aceleración unidades metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado multiplicado por un
tiempo en segundos al cuadrado y esos
segundos al cuadrado se anulan y nos
quedan solo metros de manera que este
resultado está en metros y los dibujamos
en nuestra gráfica tenemos 14.7 metros
en el primer segundo más o menos por acá
estará el segundo punto en el
desplazamiento entonces aquí en nuestro
polares 14.7 metros que pasa en el
segundo segundo
cambio en el tiempo igual a 2 nuestra
velocidad en este momento
es igual
aquí está nuestra fórmula en la
velocidad inicial que está siempre queda
es 19.6 metros sobre segundo
esto va a estar multiplicado por la
aceleración por el tiempo en este caso
el tiempo son 2 entonces está menos 9.8
va a estar multiplicado por dos y 9.8
por dos es 19 puntos 6
entonces esto se resta y nuestra
velocidad en este momento va a ser igual
a cero
aquí en nuestro segundo 2 la velocidad
es cero
aquí lo graficó esto es 0 y para
calcular nuestro desplazamiento tenemos
que
nuestra velocidad inicial multiplicada
por el tiempo de velocidad inicial por 2
nuestra velocidad inicial son 19
19.6 por 2 segundos aquí pongo las
unidades metros sobre segundo los
segundos esto se anula menos
nuestra aceleración de la gravedad
gravedad
bueno menos un medio o bueno nuestra
aceleración de la gravedad es de entre 2
que es menos 4.9 multiplicado por el
cambio del tiempo al cuadrado 2 al
cuadrado 2 por 2 4 x 4 y aquí nuestro
desplazamiento vamos a usar la
calculadora
para hacer esto entonces es
19.6
por 2
menos
4.9 por 4
y esto es igual a 19.6
entonces el desplazamiento 19 puntos 6
en el segundo 2 llega más o menos casi
el 20 por acá
19.6 que pasa en el minuto hoy perdón en
el segundo tres del tate igual a tres
la velocidad final
igual a casa así que ya vemos estamos a
mediados con los cálculos 19 puntos 6
metros sobre segundo menos
ahora es
la aceleración por el cambio del tiempo
el cambio del tiempo estrés entonces es
menos 9.8
por 3
y esto va a ser igual
menos
9.8 ahora nuestra velocidad está siendo
negativa menos 9.8 en el tiempo 3 el
desplazamiento
igual
en nuestra velocidad inicial
19.6 multiplicada por el tiempo que en
este caso son 3
menos
4.9 por 3 al cuadrado 3 por 3 viene
siendo 9 vamos a hacer entonces de nuevo
nuestra calculadora
19.6
por 3
y esto lo voy a restar
4.9 por 9
y esto me da igual
menos
14 puntos 7 menos 14 puntos 7 y en la
gráfica viene siendo
14 minutos 7
es este valor pero ahora está en sentido
contrario ahorita era positivo en esta
parte porque iba subiendo el menos me
indica que va las direcciones hacia
abajo por eso es que esta gráfica bueno
va aquí es el menos no es que se vaya
abajo o que no tengamos un
desplazamiento o negativo como tal sino
simplemente va en un sentido contrario y
aquí es cuando vemos la importancia de
los vectores de indicar la dirección del
vector con los sentidos positivos o
negativos
y bueno finalmente nuestro último tiempo
para calcular
cuando tenemos cuatro segundos cambian
el tiempo igual a cuatro velocidad final
velocidad final
igual a la velocidad inicial 19.6
metros sobre segundo menos
9.8 por 4 y esto va a ser igual
- 19.6
entonces que iba a ser menos 19.6 de la
misma manera la dirección es hacia abajo
aquí no gráfica en la velocidad el valor
de menos 9.8 en el tiempo 3 con el
segundo 3 va a ser aquí más o menos y en
el tiempo 4 su velocidad va a ser más o
menos por acá entonces uniendo estas
no quedó muy derecho pero se entiende
que esto es una línea recta y ahora para
encontrar el desplazamiento rápidamente
19.6
por el tiempo que es 4
- 4.9 por 4 al cuadrado 4 por 4 16
y para este
con el nuevo usamos nuestra calculadora
19 puntos 6
por 4
menos
4.9 por 16
y nos queda desplazamiento igual a cero
aquí de este punto en el tiempo 4 llega
de nuevo a 0 la gráfica aquí como queda
pues va a quedar
vamos a agarrar otros colores
llega aquí va por acá va subiendo
no puedo hacer mejor
más o menos por aquí
sube llega el punto máximo y empieza a
bajar
en el llega al suelo en el momento 4 o
ya no tiene el desplazamiento el
desplazamiento 0 en este tiempo
entonces bueno qué es lo que está
pasando con la con la pelota bueno
tenemos una aceleración o una
desaceleración constante en esta
velocidad por este sentido tenemos una
debido a esta aceleración negativa esta
tenemos una pendiente de menos 9.8 si
usará musical sacaremos la derivada de
ésta
curva la pendiente de esta curva y aquí
si yo estoy si yo quisiera gráficas en
esta misma gráfica del desplazamiento
expresar los vectores de velocidad en
esta misma que tendría bueno en el
tiempo cero mi velocidad o la magnitud
de este vector a 19.6 entonces la
velocidad en este momento en el cero
cuando la lancé la pelota al aire más o
menos llegó hasta acá este es mi vector
velocidad
en el primer segundo la magnitud es casi
la mitad nueve puntos la mitad 9.8
entonces más o menos el vector digo así
para lo que es el segundo el segundo
número dos
el desplazamiento pero la velocidad es
cero ya no tenemos aquí velocidad y en
el tercer segundo la velocidad la
tenemos pero en sentido negativo en
sentido hacia abajo esta magnitud y para
el minuto 4 la velocidad la magnitud es
la misma con la que iba hacia arriba
pero ahora hacia abajo justo antes de
dar contra el suelo esta es la velocidad
que tiene la pelota que lanzamos al aire
y si queremos graficar la acelera la
aceleración que la aceleración es
constante la voy a ocupar con un color
naranja para que se distinga la
aceleración es negativa y es de menos
9.8 entonces en este punto cero
la atracción de la gravedad o la
aceleración de la gravedad sigue siendo
negativa eso es constante en todo
momento va a estar el primer segundo
esta aceleración negativa va a estar
hacia acá en el tercer segundo va a
estar la es la misma magnitud de todos
estos vectores en este segundo pues va a
estar también aquí
y en el último segundo ya cuando cae la
magnitud de la aceleración como vector
va a estar aquí espero que esto les
ayuda a comprender qué es lo que sucede
cuando lanzamos un proyectil al aire